let's go now
to washington dc where wellesley is
on the line wellesley how can we help
hello gentlemen thank you for your time
um
my question is um so my boyfriend broke
up
two weeks ago and my question is if
possibly
i could have found a physical compromise
to address the issue of the different
future
goals that he and i have instead of
breaking up with them
hmm how long is your date five years
five years so wellesley see if you can
move that phone a little bit closer to
your mouth and see if we can hear you a
little bit better
much better yeah so after five years you
pulled the trigger and said no more
what what was the disconnect and values
that that made you
take that step um okay
so for example i am a homebody
and i'm close to my family and my
friends
and social circle are in close proximity
to me
but he wanted to move away from our
family
and um live the island life
move away to some caribbean island and
enjoy that kind of lifestyle
and um i um want i'm following the
ramsay baby steps
and wanna have a comfortable living
situation
and his motto is living life for the
experiences
not for the paycheck and um
what did you love about him that kept
you all together for five years
but so that's the thing so emotionally
and relationally he and i connect really
well
and we were serious about our commitment
but it was just clear that he and i just
don't have
common vision for our future um so yes
emotionally i guess
he and i connected well and um i am a
very patient person so i guess
that also is um i just went along with
it for a while
the differences i'm just quickly curious
here because we've only got about a
minute
uh did you i'm assuming you guys
discussed this and and did you ever kind
of say hey if
i can't live that life did he ever say
well i'm willing to change or did he say
well
i'm out what happened who broke up with
who
i i did the breaking up so he was not
willing to he was not willing to
compromise
um i guess he was we were willing to
compromise but
i think the issue was we didn't know
where to compromise
wellesley did you did you and him ever
go sit down and talk to a
a pre-marriage counselor together
no did you have a big blow up fight or
did you just slowly did the air just
leave this relationship and slowly the
air just left the relationship
so there's something bigger going on
here you can have
different beliefs your values can shift
and move over time if you co-create a
vision together and sometimes getting a
professional to help you walk that
is important to help you ask hard
questions and do things like that
together
but there's something else going on here
wellesley if you think you made the
wrong decision
call him back yeah but go sit down with
a professional give it one more shot
where you get an
independent voice so you can really see
what's on the table good advice dr john